Yo!! So cologne... there's a lot of them out
there. Some are a little bit too overpowering
Some you can't even smell and some are
just ugh (bad).
So how do you know what's the best
cologne for men? Well that's what we're
going to talk about in this video. So
let's get to it:
Hi Guys! If you're new here to my channel
subscribe and click the notification
bell so you won't miss any of the next
videos. Now let's start with the first
cologne: Vince Camuto Tara!! Oh my goodness, this is by far my most favorite cologne
They did an amazing job by mixing the notes together in a perfect balance and so the
top notes that you smell is citrus,
geranium, sandalwood, rhubarb, tonka bean
and vanilla it's got this very manly
smell but it's not too overpowering as
well. My wife really loves it! Every time
I wear it she gives me these nice
comments...Alright anyway it's got
this nice woody smell with a soft musk
You cannot go wrong with this one. I'll add it for in the video description as
always, so you can go ahead and check it
out
Dior Savauge. I gotta mention this one
because it's a classic and it smells
really good. The only problem I have with
it is that there's so many guys that has
this cologne, so if you don't want to
smell like every second guy that really
likes, then this cologne is not the one
for you, but it does smell great and if
it doesn't bother you then you can try
it out. The top notes are bergamot and pepper
Versace Eros! This is another one of my
favorites because this is for a guy that
is passionate, strong and confident because
when you smell you get these top notes of vanilla, mint, tonka bean, green apple
lemon and ambroxan. So it gives you
this nice fresh smell that will please
any crowd around you.
Nautica Voyage for men! Now you know that dark, leathery kind of smell?
Well this is not it. This guy
smells fresh, vibrant and kind of summery
It has a rich fusion between
dewy moss and refined woody amber as its base notes and
the top notes are green
leaves and apple and like all the other
cologne I'll add it in the video
description so you can go and check out
The customer reviews I think this guy got
over 4000 of happy reviews from guys
just like me and you.
Hugo Boss Iced!
It's got this really sexy citrus kind of
smell with top notes of icemint, vetiver and wild tea. It's got this nice uplifting smell
and it's not too overpowering as well. It
lasts a long time and this cologne is
actually perfect to wear in any kind of
casual environment also if on a date
with your girlfriend or wife. She'll try
to hang around you the whole night just
to get this smell.
Now if you're looking
for a light and clean cologne that smells
great. Dolce and Gabbana light blue is
the one for you!
It has this combination of bitter notes
and spice with sweet undertones
The main notes you get is grapefruit, bergamot, pepper, orange, rosemary and Brazilian rosewood.
So it smells great! It is light, it is
clean & it will last you the whole day
You know at the end of the day to get the
best cologne that work for you in your
personal life, you have to take this
journey of trying out different colognes
so that you can really find your own personal taste.  That might take some time but if
you want the journey to be a little bit
cheaper, then do what I did:
You don't have to buy the whole big bottle
especially if you're not sure if you
don't like it yet. You can join a
subscription-based company that sends
you a 30 day supply of cologne every month of you're choosing. So you go online.
You check out the Cologne you like: Ah! I like to try this one next time and then you
try it and just so you know: This is not a
sponsored video because as you
probably noticed on my channel
especially for a subscriber, I don't
really do those a lot. Anyway so you try
out different Cologne every month until
you develop your taste. If you like to try
it out I got my subscribers a 30%
discount code, so check it out in the video
description below to get discount off your first order.
If you liked the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video
Cheers